tonight confirmation that a discovery of
bones found at lake made are in fact
partial human remains according to the
clark county coroner that's right they
were found in the area of swim beach now
the person who found them says they were
about to wash up on shore victoria saha
is at lake mead right now with a look at
what's next to try to identify them
victoria
right now we're by the marina here at
lake mead the human remains that were
discovered yesterday are about five
minutes north of here and throughout the
day we spent our
time here at the lake we saw plenty of
people still enjoying the water despite
the latest discovery of the third set of
remains i do want to warn you guys at
home the
footage we're about to show you could be
graphic for some
[Music]
an afternoon at the beach ends with a
startling discovery
a viewer documenting his entire
experience as he discovered the remains
this discovery marking the third set of
remains found at the lake as it
continues to recede keeping the clark
county coroner's office busy it is
partial human remains at this point but
we don't have confirmation of exactly
what is there at this point a different
circumstance than the other two remains
found in may first a body was found in a
barrel weeks later kayakers found
skeletal remains those two are confirmed
to be males but we don't know how old
they are when it comes to identification
identification is the linking
of anti-mortum information to postmortem
information post being what we see now
after death and anti being what was
collected previously so we have to make
sure those things align to confirm an id
rouse says blood and tissue samples will
be sent out to be analyzed monday's
discovery of the third set of remains
didn't stop people from enjoying swim
beach it's a little unsettling for sure
and just got to keep your eyes open and
try not to swallow the water we
certainly hope they don't close the lake
because of it but we i mean i guess we
would understand if they had to do
what they got to do despite what could
resurface they're enjoying it as long as
they can even if inches of lake mead
disappear every day
rouse also says her office will exhaust
every option to identify the remains
they tell me they typically hold on to
them for about a year unless they have
any solid leads but they also said they
are working to figure out the cause of
death as well reporting from lake mead
victoria saha live local now